- Hey, everyone, I hope
you're having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens.
I'm in Weligama, Sri Lanka,
and it's an honor to be here.
I'm with David, the Hungry Tourist,
on his Best of Sri Lanka Food Tour.
Today is gonna be an
unbelievable Sri Lankan food day.
We've been invited by
Ucith, and Nick, and Lakki,
and their entire family,
who are from Weligama
in Southern Sri Lanka.
They're gonna cook for us a home-cooked,
everything cooked traditional
over fire in clay pots.
We're gonna have a lot of fun.
We're gonna eat a lot of
delicious, incredible food today.
(upbeat music)
Good, how are you?
- Good, good, good.
- [Mark] Good to see you again.
We got here a little bit early,
but they have already started cooking
some of the traditional dishes
from Southern Sri Lanka.
This is a beautiful tropical compound.
The Nelson family, they own
and operate a wood mill.
So there's logs; they're
making planks of wood.
It's gonna be all outside,
everything cooked over fire.
You can already smell
the spices in the air.
And then Aunty is in charge
of cooking in the back.
- They have an open gas stove,
and also they have the old-fashioned one--
- I'm lost.
Awesome.
Fire stove.
(bubbling)
Mango chutney.
- Try one.
- Amazing, okay, cool.
And then they have the
mango chutney prepared.
The family is very well known for this.
Oh, wow.
Oh, it's awesome man.
It's so good.
- Balance of flavor, right?
- Dude, it's sweet, a
little bit spicy, sour.
(bubbling)
- This is a tuna curry.
- [Mark] Wow, smells and dishes going,
so outside they're cooking dishes too.
There's a fish curry going.
There's shrimp that simmering down
with some herbs and spices.
The aromas, the steam, the cooking,
everything is cooked traditional,
and most dishes are cooked
in clay pots over fire.
The clay pots just build up the flavor
and keep using the clay pots.
That's one of the traditional
ways of cooking in Sri Lanka.
This is going to be a
feast that I can't wait.
The whole chair on it, that's awesome.
(laughs)
Coconut milk and shredded coconut
is an essential ingredient
in Sri Lankan food and cooking.
And they, often times I've just seen
the traditional coconut shredder
just on a little wooden stool,
but this is the deluxe version.
It's on an office chair.
Then over there, she is
slicing the gotu kola,
which is in English it's pennywort leaves.
I remember that from my
last trip to Sri Lanka.
It's a really green, really healthy,
really earthy tasting herb.
Really good.
Brinjal curry?
- Moju, moju.
- It has moju.
- [Mark] The eggplant, right?
Brinjal, brinjal.
- It's not processed, right?
Its with goraka which is--
- Let's have a taste.
- [Mark] It's okay to taste?
- [Ucith] Yeah
- [Mark] This piece?
- [Aunty] Very spicy, okay?
- [Mark] Okay
(foreign chatter)
- This is a fish curry with
garcinia, and then spices.
There's curry leaves in
it, there's chillies in it.
This is our favorite
of many in this region.
And it's specifically a Southern--
- [Ucith] She makes it the
best out of the family,
so we come all the way
here to justify that.
- Aunty makes it the best.
- [Ucith] The longer you keep
it the better the flavors.
- Oh, because of the?
(indistinct)
- And it's sour.
- Ah, because that's the garcinia.
It's very sour, right?
- Right.
- It's a very sour fish.
Okay, taste testing.
(upbeat music)
Ah yeah, mmm, that's wonderful.
Ah, there's black pepper in there, too.
You taste the black pepper,
you taste the sourness,
Ooh, the sourness
actually keeps on coming.
And Ucith says that adding some
coconut balances the flavor.
So that's the fresh grated
coconut on top of that.
(upbeat music)
- Oh wow!
That is stunning.
That is flavor.
- [Chef] The coconut milk is fresh.
- It smells incredible.
This is just an incredible
tropical paradise.
The greenery, the fruits, the vegetables,
and herbs and spices.
It's, oh man, coconuts are just blooming.
Prawns are done?
- [Man] Yeah
- Ah, here they come out right now.
What a dish!
Just getting ready to
cook a couple of dishes.
Fish roe tuna, tuna eggs, tuna roe curry!
You've got to check out the design on
the Sri Lankan stove style,
traditional clay style.
So the charcoal, the
firewood, burn down here.
The clay pot sits above here,
and then there's airflow on this side.
Coconut oil.
(sizzling)
There's onions, there's garlic,
there's curry leaves,
there's pandan leaves.
That smells incredible already,
and the dish has just begun.
(sizzling)
The cuttle fish.
- The boss (laughs).
This is my mum's oldest sister.
- Cuttle fish.
- [Mark] The greatest.
(upbeat music)
(sizzling)
Chili powder, there's curry powder,
there's pepper, I think that's
tamarind, there's turmeric.
He added all the spice
in, and then as soon as
you add that spice in it sort of cakes up,
and actually the fire is a little too low,
so we're gonna take
this back to the kitchen
where the fire is a bit bigger,
to continue the cooking.
I'm following the fish egg curry.
(upbeat music)
(sizzling)
They just added in the fish eggs,
those are some big
chunks of tuna fish eggs
just sloshing around in that spice mixture
with those onions.
(sharp tapping)
The fish eggs curry is ready now.
What he did at the end,
is he popped the egg sacks
to spill out all those eggs.
You can really see that
texture going on now.
And look how many dishes are ready.
They're all lining up.
(upbeat music)
- [Ucith] This recipe, I just made it.
- [Mark] So there's onions in here,
there's chillies, there's chicken.
- Oh yeah, mmm!
(laughing)
- [Group] That's so good!
- [Man] The chillies--
- [Mark] Oh yes, the viper chillies?
(rolling)
(popping)
So everybody has arrived now.
Most of the food, I think
actually all the food,
is ready, but she is just last-minute
crushing up some chillies
the traditional way.
And what I love is in
Sri Lanka is they use
a slab of stone with a stone roller,
and that just annihilates,
smashes, the chillies.
You can even hear them pop.
- [Man] Get the sound of that.
- [Mark] Yeah, that pop.
I need the microphone right there.
(popping chillies)
Did you crack that open already?
- I've just been sucking on this bad boy,
well there's not much meat on there left,
because it's all in my stomach.
- [Tim] I had, like, four of them!
- [Abram] And then just
a couple of naked seeds.
- [Tim] Fricking amazing.
Mark, we're doing a durian
tour, let's do a durian tour.
We need to try them all!
- [Abram] Go check it out, my man.
- [Mark] Oh yes, how's that durian?
- [Tim] Awesome.
- [Mark] Oh, thank you.
(upbeat music)
Mmm, mmm!
Oh yeah!
Oh yeah, it's amazing,
it's so creamy, mmm!
Okay, what she just brought over,
this is a family recipe,
this is a pork curry.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
- Amazing flavor.
- That skin crunches too.
You get the crunch of that skin,
the flavor of the cake up of curry paste
on each piece of meat.
- [Blue T-Shirt Man] Sweet potato.
- Oh, sweet potato.
Fried slices of sweet potato,
dusted in chili powder.
Oh man, and another durian.
Oh this one is even better!
Softer, a hint more of bitterness to it.
- [Woman] Cassava.
- [Man] So basically it's sweet cassava,
with kochi sambar.
You've got to put this on top of that.
- Like a shredded cassava
mash-up, with pork curry.
Oh wow!
- That's shredded cassava so it has
a totally different texture, more starchy.
Mmm, packed full of flavor.
That's insane, that's amazing.
The next one?
- [Man] Do them together.
- [Mark] The chicken salad
and the sweet potato.
This is good.
(laughing)
- The onions are amazing!
- There's a citrusy taste.
We're just snacking out
of control right now.
We can't help ourselves, it's too good!
(upbeat music)
Ooh, we've got moringa leaves.
We're all lining up, self service,
there's like at least 12 different dishes
plus a bunch of different garnishes,
a bunch of different
pickles, a bunch of salads.
There's rice, it's just
a bounty of a feast.
It's beautiful, amazing
people, amazing hospitality,
the generosity, it's like an all-time
high of excitement, anticipation,
and beauty of culture,
food, and hospitality.
(upbeat music)
I'm going to go for a
little bit of both rice.
There's white rice, and there's red rice.
Put the red rice on here.
This is the brinjal curry, you can see
that the brinjal is eggplant.
It's fried, the shallots in here,
there's chillies in here,
you've got to cup it.
Pennywort mix, sambal.
Oh, another dish!
Oh, that one is the jack fruit curry.
Jack fruit curry, right?
Prawns curry; You can see the cinnamon,
you can see the curry leaves in here.
Oh wow, and I'm going
to go with a little bit
of this sauce on my rice.
Another sambal, but I
think this is made with
something fried and crunchy.
Dry curry, again made
with fish eggs, fish roe.
I think this is also some
type of a sambal with coconut,
so I'll put this over the
sambal side of my plate.
This is a tuna curry, but
made with the garcenia,
with that sourness.
Wow, this is just unbelievable.
This is the dish that we
saw him fully prepare,
the fish eggs curry.
Look at that texture, you can see how he
popped those egg sacks just
to let all the eggs bloom out.
This one, I believe, is coconut.
We can see the curry leaves in here and
you can see the little baby shrimp.
I think this is the one I tasted.
This is the jack fruit curry.
Hearty and rich and fulfilling.
This one is the pineapple curry.
String beans, they go on.
I think this is a fish curry as well.
Right on top, oh you can
no longer see the rice.
Finish this off with a little
bit of the mango chutney
which I also sampled,
which is unbelievable good.
Okay, there is rice under here.
I tried to get everything.
A little bit of all of the dishes,
and there is rice below there, but it's
completely covered in a layer of,
there's at least a dozen
different curries here,
plus all the garnishes,
plus all the sambals,
plus all the, it's just beautiful.
I think I'm going to begin
with whatever is in the center.
I think that's a mix of both the,
I think that's a mix of
the jack fruit curry,
plus some of the pineapple curry.
You can see the curry leaves in there.
Wow.
Got some of the pineapple curry in there.
You got some of that sweet, tart flavor,
plus that black pepper in there.
There's also a tomatoey jam.
The squid here, and that's
also the fish roe curry.
You can see that texture, the fish roe
just popping out of there.
Wow.
The fish roe in unbelievable!
It has a really soft texture
and smoky taste to it.
You taste that roasted curry powder.
(upbeat music)
That is spectacular.
Revolve my plate over to those gotu kola.
Really green-tasting, really you taste
the coconut in there too,
the shredded coconut.
Actually, in that bite
I also had a bite of
the eggplant, the brinjal curry.
The eggplant is fried then
mixed with the spices,
so it has a sweet caramelized taste to it.
(upbeat music)
Oh wow!
Okay, moving on to the shrimp now.
I think I'm gonna eat this whole thing!
What's amazing is a lot of the dishes
use similar spices in common,
but all of the dishes have a different,
unique taste to them.
A few different ingredients, and then just
all of them together just
form a harmony on your plate.
They're all unique, they're
all ultra-flavorful,
the spices just stand out.
The way they've been cooked over the fire,
you can taste the smoke in the dishes.
This is the jack fruit curry?
- [Server] Yeah
- Okay, cool, awesome.
I missed a dish, this
is a jack fruit curry
with coconut milk.
The jack fruit is not fully ripe,
but not fully young either.
It has different textures to it.
You taste the seeds
which are more potatoey.
Thank you so much,
- You're welcome, man.
- This food is stunning.
- It's good having you here.
- It's really an honor to be here.
You guys have taken such good care of us.
- Thank you so much.
- The authenticity of the food,
everything about this, the
company, our entire group,
and their entire hospitality.
- It's an honor having you here, man.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
And we are still digging in.
I didn't realize that plate
of food really added up.
- [Ucith] Yeah, you ate
a lot more than that!
- Dude, that was a pretty
massive plate of food,
I'm still working on it, happily!
Just loving every single bite,
my taste buds are just
overflowing with deliciousness!
Final bite from this plate, I saved
a last fish, almost like
a tube, like a shoot.
The plates are deep, the
food just kept adding up.
That was stunning!
(upbeat music)
And I almost, almost,
forgot about the crab curry!
That is the next dish.
Hello there
- Drenched, drenched in juice, baby!
- [Mark] Have you taken a
couple of showers during lunch?
- That's loving life!
I'm going to have to go for
another shower in a few minutes.
(laughing)
- [Mark] I think I might join you.
I had almost forgotten
about the crab curry.
- [Bald Man] I am just covered,
sweat, snot, crab juice.
(Mark laughing)
Because it's the blue crab
it's easier to crack that.
I got that crab de-shelled,
mix it with the sauce.
Oh wow, that crab is stunning as well!
(crunching)
When you bite that
shell, the juices run out
on to your chin, oh man!
- You know, with these
crabs you don't even
need the crackers,
- No, no
you just bite into them.
- Yeah, this type of blue crab,
that's one of the benefits
of it, the shell is just so thin.
And then the juice, the curry, just seeps
into crab into the shell.
And the meat is so tasty!
(rapid chatter)
- [Announcer] Welcome to
Weligama Food Festival,
- Alright, I'm tapping out
- Yes!
- Substitution! It's all you, Mark.
- Dude, I need a shower with you!
(laughing)
Wow, the camera is covered in crab,
my face is covered in crab and curry,
good thing there's a hose over here!
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
The post-curry head-wash!
- This is what's needed!
Your turn!
- That's just too tempting!
Oh yes, oh wow, that feels wonderful!
What a meal!
Dude, the digestive-sweats,
the chili curry-sweats.
(foreign chatter)
(splashing)
- [Lakki] You see this, this is, you don't
get this in normal coconuts,
it's like jelly inside.
You put treacle on it.
- Wow
You take it with the honey.
- [David] It's amazing.
It's amazing, it's the whole thing, huh?
- [Lakki] Hold on, hold
on, put some of this--
- Hit me, baby, sweet nectar!
Wow, it's so soft!
- [Lakki] It's like gel, right?
(sharp tapping)
(cheering)
- [David] Where's the sugar,
the syrup, the palm sugar?
Sugar, sugar?
Let me tell you if it's good first.
Wait, wait.
Oh my God.
- Let me just have a bite.
That's so soft,
that's so soft, so silky smooth.
You're just drowning in the
coconut sugar and palm syrup.
- Dikiri
Dikiri
- Dikiri?
- Dikiri.
That is like a rare breed
of a mutant coconut.
- Waited three weeks to
get five dikiri coconuts.
- [Mark] Thank you!
- You're welcome, man.
- It is a natural wonder of
the world, without a doubt.
- Thank you very much.
- [Mark] Awesome, incredible.
- It was very nice meeting you.
- [Mark] Thank you, you too.
Thank you so much, that was amazing.
Oh yes, thank you so much!
Thank you, man.
He is one of the chefs, amazing!
- Thank you so much.
- [Mark] Thank so much, thank you, Mama,
for your amazing hospitality
and for hosting us,
and for your food, it's incredible!
(upbeat music)
(splash)
(laughing)
- Ah, you hit your butt!
Wow, okay, we made it back.
Do not go on that slide after a huge meal,
I just bottomed out!
That was an unbelievable lunch,
the food, the hospitality, the culture,
the Sri Lankan culture, that was just
an extraordinary, memorable meal.
Very special, a privilege
to have that opportunity.
I want to say a massive
thank you to Ucith,
to Nick, to Lakki, to Uncle, to Aunty,
to the entire Nelson Family in Weligama.
That was unbelievable.
Amazing food, amazing experience
and a learning opportunity.
I want to say a massive thank you to
everybody who prepared the food,
everybody we interacted
with, and hung out with,
and to David, The Hungry Tourist,
for arranging this entire tour.
I'll have all of their links
in the description box below,
so you can check them
out, and I want to say
a huge thank you to you
for watching this video,
please remember to give it a thumbs up
if you enjoyed it, and
leave a comment below.
I'd love to hear from you, and if you're
not already subscribed,
click subscribe now
and also click the
little bell icon so that
you get notified of the
next video that I publish.
Thanks again for watching,
I'll see you on the next video.